sur cette photo j'ai deux ans pendant
longtemps je les regardais dans l'album
de famille cherchant sur mon visage les
indices de mon futur
je me voyais marché dans l'air déterminé
qu'à laon mais pas sur ceux de ma nounou
est rica
puis un jour j'ai compris que
l'important était aussi dans le décor
sur cette photo l'arrière-plan et celui
d'un hôpital
l'hôpital psychiatrique de earth ou
travailler mes parents alors jeune
médecin celui humanum ou rentrer dormir
chaque soir après m'avoir gardé
des années cette photo est resté bien
rangés dans l'album de famille jusqu'à
ce que je ressente le besoin de
confronter mes souvenirs à ce qu'on me
renvoyer du monde de la psychiatrie
un univers violent dangereux et
imprévisible dont il faudrait que la
société se protègent
l'hôpital de mes souvenirs où je pouvais
côtoyé librement les patients avait t-il
exister dans la réalité etait-ce une
autre époque
reste-t-il quelque chose de ce qui était
mon monde normal
quand tu es né et que je devais
reprendre le travail je me disais
il faudrait que quelqu'un puisse la
garder et alors en fait c'est par une
autre malade qui faisait la lessive pour
ton père
qui a dit mais il ya erika qui travaille
à la lingerie
qui est
fiable
vous devriez demander donc ça s'est fait
comme ça
et du coup elle concerne garder quand
j'avais également quelques mois
[Musique]
au début elle avait juste à te promener
quand tu étais toute prête habillé tout
promener la voiture d'enfant
dans le parc et puis petit à petit je
lui ai appris à te changer mais vraiment
en faisant très progressivement parce
que j'étais quand même
attentive à voir comment elle se
débrouillait bien se débrouiller comme
un bien
ou non elle était très attachée à toi et
te trouver la
plus jolie bébé qu'on puisse imaginer et
elle était toujours très attentive
fameuse épisode de la chute dans
l'escalier
elle n'a pas craint de descendre
l'escalier comme sur un toboggan parce
qu'elle voulait pas à te lâcher qu'elle
tenait contre elles n'ont non là elle a
été d'un dévouement tout à fait
remarquable et très
si je disais vous donnez à manger ce
petit pot telle chose elle fait
exactement ce que je disais donc
été très scrupuleuse ou
son histoire c'était tout simplement une
famille nombreuse en situation difficile
elle était comme adolescente placé dans
une maison qu'appuyer des personnes
âgées géré par des bonnes soeurs et elle
était un peu caractériel elle a eu des
problèmes de comportement des problèmes
avec les bonnes soeurs elle s'est
retrouvé hospitalisé
à hoerdt à l'âge de 17 ans alors s'il y
avait une famille qui la réclame elle
serait sans doute sorti au bout d'une ou
deux semaines et comme personne ne l'a
réclamé quelques années plus tard elle
était toujours là
[Musique]
vu de l'extérieur et vu d'aujourd'hui on
peut dire tiens c'est quand même étrange
faire garder ses enfants par des malades
il faut voir dans le contexte de
l'époque
les malades qui n'avaient pas été
recherchée par leur famille même
complètement stabilisé ne sortait pas de
l'hôpital puisqu'il n'avait pas d'argent
qu'ils n'avaient aucun moyen de vivre à
l'extérieur et il travaillait soit dans
des cuisines lingerie jardins de
l'hôpital soit chez les médecins et
c'était des malades
l'algérie dès maintenant ne serait plus
hospitalisés mais qui dans le contexte
de l'époque étaient obligés de rester à
l'hôpital puisqu'il y avait personne qui
qu'ils pouvaient s'en occuper autrement
cette époque je les découvertes dans le
livre comme mon père a écrit il ya peu
une fois à la retraite
loin de l'homme stricte et sévère que
j'ai toujours connu il y livre ses
impressions de jeunes 6-4 formé dans les
années 60 lors du grand mouvement de
désaliénation apparus en réaction aux
horreurs de la guerre
les patients psychiatriques ont été
parmi les premiers sacrifiés des
chambres à gaz
quarante mille sont morts de faim au
sein même des hôpitaux
pour cette génération grandi dans
l'après guerre l'enfermement
psychiatrique ressemble à l'univers
concentrationnaire nazi de façon
intolérable
d'autant que le chaos de la guerre a
aussi révélé que les patients
psychiatriques était capable de guérir
à l'hôpital de saintes allemands ou des
résistants se cache parmi les
pensionnaires on découvre que ceux ci
font d'énormes progrès au contact des
personnes venues de l'extérieur
ces expériences inédites influence la
psychiatrie du moins en théorie
car en 68 ce quand mes parents jeunes
internes arrive pour la première fois
dans l'hôpital de hoerdt ils font la
découverte d'une autre réalité
[Musique]
la toute première fois que j'ai vu
l'hôpital c'était l'été l'été 68 avant
que je commence à y travailler
j'avais rendez vous avec le directeur et
on a été surtout frappé par les cris
les t'écris épouvantable qu'on entendait
bien sûr même sans entrer dans les
bâtiments
[Musique]
les salles communes les bonnes soeurs de
l'allée centrale avec chapelle lingerie
salle des fêtes disons la zone neutre à
droite les services de femmes à gauche
les services d'hommes
toutes les femmes avaient la même coupe
de cheveux taillés par les infirmières
les mêmes robes tablier
les hommes aussi même costume c'était
assez effrayant et les malades étaient
enfermés la nuit dans dans ces grands
dortoirs et ils devaient uriner dans des
boîtes de conserves puisqu'ils n'avaient
pas accès aux toilettes
c'est le matin quand on ouvrait les
portes c'était
assez s'il faut quoi
c'était le fonctionnement habituel de la
psychiatrie mais qui effectivement dans
les années 60 a fait pas tellement
évolué au fil des décennies
on
[Musique]
pour la première fois je retourne dans
l'hôpital de hoerdt aujourd'hui
désaffectée
je parcours les salles communes je
découvre le pavillon celui des femmes à
l'époque où a débuté mon père est où
vivent et eric à
[Musique]
cet endroit m'impressionne
j'y trouve les traces de ces vies
entières passées dans l'hôpital
mais aussi de l'apaisement dans ses
beaux bâtiments faits pour durer des
siècles est désormais perdu dans la
végétation
quels souvenirs à garder erika de ces
années
je réalise que je n'ai jamais abordé ce
sujet avec mon ancienne nounou
pas plus que je ne me suis demandé si
j'aurais pu comme ma mère avoir
confiance au point de confier mes
enfants à une patiente de l'hôpital
cette question se pose à moi lors de
cette visite à hoerdt lorsque je prends
conscience de ce qu'il y avait vraiment
dans l'arrière plan de la photo si
souvent regardés
j'espère qu'elle va nous admet civile
bonjour à
mais
si tu manges arrives tu à nu
bougez pas
nous avons
je viens justement c'est une bien suivre
la voie que les faits
elle a matter of sur son mari tu vas pas
reconnu non pas tout de suite c'est la
têt nouvel ouvrage
tu as plus léché le plan ses poussins
toi aussi tu as changé tapis des cheveux
non pour clé non sur 14 comme maman ça
fait longtemps qu'on sait pas sûrs mais
oui mais ça fait quoi deux ans je peux
plus sortir quand le cheveu en cô mais
pas tenir tout
nous je peux prouver là vous pouvez
parler en confiance on est entre nous
j'ai pas le train et le téléphone parce
que je voulais et appelé oui ça fait
déjà un bout de
trois ans
je ne reçois plus c'est plus téléphone
non
mais sinon je sais pas le droit de dire
où va le dire pourquoi taper le
téléphone ouais moi de pouvoir de la
chance alors pour réussir à tout voir
puis je me téléphoner chez télé crochet
chez mon ami vous renouvelle installer
les fans non j'ai pas le droit
ne peux pas te le dire - il faut taper
droit d'installer les femmes non j'ai
plus le troll et les
et pour mon reportage je me demandais ce
que tu as des souvenirs de de comment ça
se passait avec nous à l'hôpital quand
on était enfant
bien bien
vingt trois enfants s'était pas trop de
travail mais là à mashhad ça me
dérangeait pas du tout nous
jamais thérage par ailleurs
ça me plait gergorin
je m'amusais avec vous
non non c'est vrai ma petite fille comme
ça
j'étais avec une jolie robe rouge avec
des fleurs régime photo bien un ouais
voilà je résume à la tu veux la voir
voyez je pensais tout j'ai pas oublier
que vous dites c'est une fois
ça je ne peux pas oublier
quand je te prie tend les bras j'étais
en haut pour faire les lits étaient à
côté - ai-je déportés et je bascule et
l'escalier et maman a dit ou n'a rien
c'est pas vrai voilà et ça
et ça je vais pas oublier
doit elle avait pas mal et moi nous
jeter pjak plus tard tommy pas quand
j'étais petit rien si
je rappelle par un nom voilà mais moi
j'ai aussi il ya des pas
qui suit
c'est moi c'est l'hôpital jamais quand
même pas 8 h nicolas rossi michel 1 1
non je crois pas que nous sommes si je
te dis qui je veux
mais quelle qui à laterrière la caravane
non c'est la maison des bataillons sa as
maintenant ça ne vient pas taillé en
jeu la vue ça vous dit
il m'a demandé comment j'allais
jacques bataillon ethical un de mes
parents dans l'hôpital dachstein où nous
avons vécu à partir de 1975
l'erika nous ya suivi et avec son
salaire d'employés de maison elle a pu
louer le studio où elle habite toujours
je ne me souviens plus d'allant earth
mais je la revois erstein c'est dans cet
hôpital que j'ai mes souvenirs d'enfance
entre les logements de fonction et le
parc où j'allais jouer le soir après
l'école comme les autres enfants de
médecins
nous adorions cet endroit à l'
architecture ouverte conçue sur les
principes de la nouvelle psychiatrie il
y avait un terrain de jeu à côté des
logements de fonction mais le terrain de
jeu nous envoyait au sens beaucoup plus
large puisque on se déplace et
finalement toute la journée à vélo et le
terrain de jeu c'était jusque dans
l'hôpital
[Musique]
on franchissait très facilement un
simple portail qui était pas forcément
toujours fermée à clef au début très peu
même et alors là c'est en dd kilomètres
de possibilités à vélo pour pour se
promener est allé à travers des petits
des petits chemins et croient jusqu'au
tonus oui jusqu'au tennis jusqu'au
terrain de foot le tennis tout au fond
et la possibilité de croiser et
décroiser des malades de croiser des
gens qui travaillaient là est vraiment
allumé un peu comment ça se passe quand
vous ressentez ça j'ai pas souvenir
d'avoir été inquiète d'avoir eu peur
d'abord comme je disais on était à vélo
donc à la rigueur on avait ce sentiment
de pouvoir d'état les six vraiment si
vraiment on avait un moment d'inquiétude
mais c'était pas le cas c'était pas le
cas et en général c'était c'était plutôt
respectueux c'était c'était se dire
bonjour tout simplement certains avaient
envie ou vraiment besoin de discuter
et
enfin moi je trouvais ça j'ai trouvé que
ça nous ça nous a apporté une forme de
de tolérance et d'humilité c'est oui moi
je crois que c'était une bonne école de
vie en société et ministre et de
confiance de dire les enfants
les choses il est vrai que les malades
franchement dangereux en principe
circuler pas dans le parc et puis
d'ailleurs qu'est ce qui est dangereux
des gens qu'ils peuvent être dangereux
pendant un mois et puis être d'ailleurs
d'ailleurs pratiquement tous les malades
hospitalisés ressorti un jour ou l'autre
je rencontre encore là qui à l'époque
était considérée comme dangereuse dans
le plus haut ils sont mon aimable et je
redis avec nous et d'aller vivre dans un
hôpital avec sa famille un projet qui
engage au delà ce sont sa vie
professionnelle puisque ce point là
vivent dans l'hôpital c'est quelque
chose que vous aviez réfléchi vous aime
pas c'est normal pour le coup oui on se
croit quand ça jamais vraiment
questionné au dessus moi j'ai fait
c'est même une question que je pense
mais jamais venu à l'esprit
beaucoup de choses ont changé depuis
qu'en 1952 a été généralisé l'emploi des
neuroleptiques des médicaments qui ont
pour effet de calmer immédiatement les
plus agitées depuis cette date les
hôpitaux psychiatriques ont été repensés
les aliénés sont devenus des malades que
l'on garde le moins de temps possible
les médecins et infirmiers sont devenus
en plus des psychologues et des
animateurs d'activités d'éveil puisqu'il
fallait reconstruire un hôpital autant
le faire en tenant compte de l'évolution
de la thérapeutique c'est ainsi que
erstein a été créé sur un site de 29
hectares un véritable petit village avec
son église sont et à sa salle de sport
tout cela dans un cadre de verdure à la
lisière de la forêt les premiers malades
qui arriveront dès le début de la
semaine prochaine seront répartis par
petits groupes dans des pavillons
disposant de tout le complot c'est une
expérience nouvelle jeu
il va bien sûr se poser un certain
nombre de problèmes nous sommes encore
un peu
de brouillard sur un plan purement
médical s'il n'y a pas quelque chose ou
est ce une nouvelle aussi adopté en
données coeur on se trouve plus loin
d'hôpital avec des blocs mais quelque
chose du village oui
nous avons donc ici des pavillons les
unités de 25 lits avec un espace qui
permet d'éviter la promiscuité des rades
ces images seront sans doute les salles
de montre à dans ce film
s'il parle volontiers au reporter de fr3
venue l'interviewer ce printemps 74 il
refuse aujourd'hui de répondre à mes
questions
convoqué cette période d'expérimentation
dans laquelle il se disait déjà dans le
brouillard n'est sans doute pas facile
pas plus que de reconnaître les
tâtonnements de cette époque que
pourtant jacques bataille on me raconte
son problème
je me laisse en
2010 on va faire un peu différent c'est
ce que j'ai
quand je suis arrivé j'ai
j'ai effectivement fait la mixité dans
les pavillons et j'ai
changé je devais avoir trois pavillons
sous ma responsabilité
dans deux pavillons je laisser les
portes ouvertes la journée par la nuit
et puis on a développé les hôpitaux de
jour puisque sans aller jusqu'aux tests
de l'antipsychiatrie qui explique que
l'hôpital rend malade
si on met pas les gens le bit à
l'épisode pas malade s'en aller si loin
il est vrai que des gens qui ont des
problèmes psychiatriques entre autres
sont souvent mieux chez eux dans leur
domicile ou sur leur lieu de travail que
dans un hôpital
et ensuite le mouvement s'est continuée
est ce qui fait que les services
hospitaliers se sont vidés quoi même
façon qu'il ya des équipes qui peut
éventuellement y avoir d internement
arbitraire on peut dire qu'il ya aussi
des cas où il ya eu des externats mamby
traire des gens qui est sorti trop tôt
trop vite de l'hôpital quoi aride et
russie oui ou par briand balle et 2,20
les rues les tre maintenant ça devient
plus les moyens que l'idéologie
actuellement
sa victoire c'était plus les biologique
les moyens
dans les archives je découvre que ses
sorties prématurées par idéologie ont pu
mettre en danger certaines personnes non
préparés à la vie autonome
il est aussi arrivé que les fugues de
patients désorientés se termine de façon
tragique dans la forêt
cela a entraîné le retour de quelques
clés aux portes des pavillons mais cet
état d'esprit d'un hôpital ouvert a
toutefois perdurer si bien qu'entre mon
enfance et celle de mon petit frère dans
les années 90 il ya peu des différences
je passais voir maman à son service pour
chercher ou déposer un courrier ou un
truc qu'elle a oublié puis après
j'allais à côté dans la carrière pour
faire ma séance d'équitation au mildiou
l'hôpital le début c'était un club
psychothérapique soins du malade par le
cheval et puis petit à petit ce club a
proposé des séances au personnel et aux
enfants des personnels de l'hôpital et
puis après c'est devenu un commercial
qui était encore sous contrat avec
l'hôpital pour faire des prestations
d'équité rapide mais tout en étant
ouvert sur l'hôpital et finalement une
partie du club était dans l'hôpital à
une partie du club étaient à l'extérieur
mais enfin moi mais bon je fais le
concours par exemple basson boxe était
dans l'hôpital les dimanches matins on
avait
plusieurs camions qui débarquait avec au
plus fort de l'époque les centaines de
cavaliers qui étaient là pour des
concours sur des week-ends entiers
c'est quand le club on va dire c'était
l'apogée du club des travaux d'entretien
été réalisée par des seat et donc des
patients qui sont encadrés et soigné par
le travail puisque les moniteurs
d'équitation alors certains moniteurs
avaient une formation pédagogique pour
pour les malades et puis de l'autre et
de l'autre côté il y avait également des
infirmiers qui avaient une formation
pour l'univers du cheval je savais pas
forcément qu'ils étaient malades qui
était personnelle à cette époque
vous voyez pas la différence en tant
qu'enfant finalement
tu voyais pas la différence oui entre
voilà un gars habillés en bleu est un
gars bien en bleu
j'ai su plus tard que ben certains
c'était des seat et parce qu'on voyait
quand même du point de vue
comportemental il y avait
quelque chose qui faisait voir qu'ils
étaient des patients
aujourd'hui ça paraît très complètement
impossible invraisemblable pourquoi pour
des raisons réglementaires ou parce que
l'époque a changé pour un fou pour des
pour des révélations réglementaire pour
des questions d'assurance et de
responsabilité puisque finalement
c'était des moments pendant ces concours
ou
concours était à cheval entre l'hôpital
et l'extérieur de l'enceinte de
l'hôpital tout a été ouvert parce que
les gens pourraient circuler et puis dix
mètres plus loin il y avait la porte des
paviens
[Musique]
il
le centre d'équithérapie a depuis
disparu mais ce n'est pas le seul
changement que je découvre en repassant
devant l'hôpital d'erstein le terrain de
jeu et la piscine sont aussi à l'abandon
comme les anciens services de mon père
au fond du parc sans doute la
conséquence de la baisse du nombre de
lits et du manque de moyens d'une
psychiatrie qu'on dit maintenant
paupérisée voir exemple
pourtant je vois qu'un bâtiment immense
et flambant neufs trône au centre du
parc à la place de plusieurs des anciens
pavillons qui ont été rasés
à l'arrière quelques-unes des anciennes
constructions sont toujours occupés mais
l'activité semble désormais concentrées
dans le gros escargot blanc
je contacte le directeur pour comprendre
ce qu'est devenu l'hôpital de mont en
france
après quelques mois de patience il
m'autorise à venir avec une caméra
donc au badge la porte s'ouvre
yona la zone où il ya les bureaux en
face au nahd bourg en avionique et vitré
et l'unité de soin commence en deux
parties de chaque côté
oui il revient
je suis vite oppressés par ces sas à
franchir ces écrans vidéo qui surveille
les couloirs dans le bureau infirmiers
aux airs de tour de contrôle je me sens
davantage dans l'ambiance d'une prison
que dans celle d'un hôpital
on a toujours ce regard de soignants de
psychiatrie ou à là où on a appris avec
justement enfermer les patients cette
crainte de leur laisser trop de liberté
aussi
censé me demande de la société que les
patients soient enfermés en psychiatrie
donc nous aussi on doit on doit répondre
à cette demande et m que tout montant
sécurité on va juste faire un
aller-retour à la cafet
aurait ramené à manger
rien pas d'habits
et vous disiez la demande de la société
c'est à dire c'était beaucoup de passion
ici qui sont hospitalisés sous la
contrainte c'est ça à la demande de
l'état c'est ça c'est ça de façon
contrainte pas forcément à demande de
l'état la demande des médecins à
demandes de proches aussi un des proches
qui demande l'hospitalisation de
quelques uns de leurs familles qui
voient là qu'ils se sentent eux aussi en
sécurité quand le patient est ici entre
deux bandes m'a soigné qu'on puisse
observer l'évaluer
on appelle ça un service fermé parce que
parce que le patient n'a pas la
possibilité d'ouvrir lui même la porte
ouais fait regarder ça faisait quelque
chose de prescrire
vous ennuyer marin c'est bien mais quand
vous avez pas le droit de sortir c'est
compliqué hein papa way
attentats je suis pas garder le chien
termine après il ya des moments sur
certaines prises en charge
pose plus la question est ce que ce
qu'on fait pour le patient c'est
vraiment du soin ou est ce que c'est
juste
la surveillance à proprement parler
il ya des hospitalisations qui sont
demandées niveau préfectoral suite à une
garde à vue le patient est envoyé chez
nous en psychiatrie alors que ce que sa
place est vraiment en psychiatrie
on a une grosse période suite aux
attentats où on a eu pas mal de gens qui
étaient affichés par exemple et qui est
hospitalisée chez nous parce qu'il y
avait une crainte à l'extérieur et que
peut-être pas
nécessité de mettre
mettre en prison et du coup on mettait a
tendance à mettre en psychiatrie parce
que il ya sept
cette idée que c'est fermé et qu' ils
sont ils sont
rangés en quelque sorte
vous attendez d'un souper un après midi
comme la suite
va faire du bien
[Musique]
mais pas une non
vous avez pas me sentir bien
mais là j'avoue même nom et
la lâcheté
cospar a joué
dans ce coup là on retrouve également
sur notre gauche les chambres de soins
intensifs donc pareil on n'y va mon bac
il ya trois champs de soins intensifs
qu'on appelle main en chambre
d'isolement ça a changé depuis l'an
dernier les dernières recommandations de
la has on appelle ça nouveau chambre
d'isolement ont des patients sur
prescription en difficulté en agitation
des fois leur propre demorand pour se
sentir plus contenue ces réponses des
procédures très précises
d'indications technique dans la chambre
il ya uniquement indiqué scellés essonne
sur lequel on peut
sanguin patient si besoin on le fait le
moins souvent possible mais ça nous
arrive et un ca lisieux
3 cellules d'isolement pour un service
de 32 lits 9 dans le bâtiment de 90 10
cela me paraît beaucoup en tout cas
beaucoup plus qu'à l'époque de mon
enfance d'autant qu'il est très rare que
ces cellules d'isolement ne soient pas
toutes occupées
il ya toujours deux portes une chambre
de soins intensifs en chambre
d'isolement parce que si un premier
sécurité on peut rentrer des deux côtés
on a vu un patient qui a démonté une
fenêtre il avait un morceau tu as fait
naître dans la main s'il est des
recettes pour te là on rentre pas de
votre porte et on ouvre cette porte
remets moment ça permet de débiter toute
agression c'est pas fréquent mais mieux
vaut prévenir avant les outils il faut
pour prévenir
et ils vont mange dans le couloir en
général alors un petit point très
positif au bout de couloir
on a un accès à l'extérieur
qui donne sur une terrasse couverte mais
sur un jardin qui permet quand même de
l'or des surveillants en chambre de
l'assesseur tuer le patient pour fumer
est aussi se promener un peu dégoûté les
gens
on comprend que c'est utile enfin c'est
quelque chose qui est finalement assez
utilisé parce que effectivement
ce n'est se serait vu comme nécessaire
par les soignants et je pense par les
médecins aussi et en même temps c'est
très souvent décrié quand on y verra
port du contrôleur des lieux de
privation de liberté qui dit en france
il ya beaucoup trop de recours à
l'isolément c'est vraiment un cheval de
bataille aujourd'hui de dix minutes en
psychiatrie tous ces gens qui sont
contre les mises en isolement je les
entends mais c'est pas c'est pas dans le
sens où on le puits dit on le met en
isolement pour qu'on soit tranquilles
voit le passant qui en isolement ils
demandent plus de plus de
plus de besoins humains pour s'en
occuper qu'on va quand il c'est l'heure
du repas ça va soumettre quatre
personnes qui s'occupent de lui à ce
moment là c'est vraiment du soin
intensif c'est pour sa compagne de
chambre soit intensifiée dans ce sens là
faut aussi se dire que parfois on a si
on est en train de passer on a trente et
un autres patients qui sont autour et on
peut pas prendre de risques pour ses
trente et un autre patient non plus donc
levée de la mesure de celle ci il a pu
réintégrer la sombre 210 ses habits
fermée à clé
comment les infirmiers lille t-il ces
lieux fermés ils y sont eux aussi
assigné à résidence alors que les
médecins s'absente pour consulter en
dehors de l'hôpital
ça s'est mal passé il était à côté de
françois et puis casser les oreilles et
où françois dû quitter la table sinon
seraient clashes persécutés
dans le service travaille plusieurs
générations d'infirmiers psychiatriques
mais tous même les plus jeunes ont connu
les bâtiments des années 70
le fait que les pavillons étaient comme
j'étais avant savez un aspect
colonie de vacances les gens est entré
dans leur pavillon c'était chez eux bon
voila il est après ils les aller se
balader enfin c'est vrai que c'était
ouvert sur la nature c'était cette fiche
à mon âge on n'était jamais c'était la
belle époque effectivement
pas c'est pas une question d'époque si
je vous entends c'est aussi une question
de lieu d'architecturé c'est pas juste
de la nostalgie du passé ouais il ya oui
aussi oui mais c'était un petit bungalow
c'était nos banques à d'autres rentrer
chez nous cette fin de deuxième mais ce
jour là
et ici bah si c'est un hôpital ici ça
n'a lieu de travail baïri pas cette
bulle comme ya actuellement les
soignants était et au centre on était
tout le temps tout le temps avec les
patients quoi là c'est vrai que les
ordinateurs sont là bas les soignants
sont
notamment de choses à écrire tout le
temps que voilà on est on est beaucoup
plus isolé des patients il faut aller au
contact alors qu'avant le contact
faisait naturellement quoi
bon jouer tout le temps aux cartes c'est
bête hein jacques attaquent nos patients
mais on y avait cette relation tout le
temps de confiance
si j'ai ainsi encore mais c'est plus
pareil on a une espèce de barrières
c'est vrai que cette sauce à ça ça me
pue ça ça nous ça ne coupent de quoi
l assassinat piette activités on est
installé à aller vite quoi en plein
après-midi après on est moins voilà il
ya un poste infirmier de journée qui est
qui a disparu ceci beaucoup ce à quoi on
est moins nombreux
et les passions reste aussi l'auto il va
se moins de temps
actuellement les patients non ils
répondent tant
ils restent moins longtemps
j'aurais aimé filmer les patients du
service mais ceux ci ne sont pas en état
de me répondre et ne le seront sans
doute pas avant des mois des années
le temps de la psychiatrie reste
terriblement long
heureusement je rencontre no man après
plusieurs séjours dans l'hôpital
d'erstein il revient aujourd'hui
partager son vécu pour redonner espoir
aux patients sans fermer
aujourd'hui j'y crois il est possible
quand le chemin je sois de nouveau
hospitalisé que ce soit de nouveau en
crise il est possible que je prenne un
mauvais détour qui l'entourent vous ne
l'a jamais fait je voudrais dire que
notre maladie n'est pas incurable elle
peut se soigner avec la famille les amis
le personnel du corps médical évidemment
nous mêmes je suis atteint de
schizophrénie chine est un grand bravo
aux nouvelles venues c'est très fort en
termes d'impact ce que vous dites même
sur les professionnels de santé parce
que d'un rien ne remplace la crédibilité
du réel finalement qui est mieux placé
que vous pour parler du rétablissement
puisque vous le vivez
j'étais hospitalisée le suspendre à
aulus mois une fois et
c'était changement de médicaments
changement de médicaments changement
médicaments tout le temps tout le temps
tout le temps c'est la salle des sports
si la salle de sport où il ya de
l'escala de la musculation tout ça
vous avez souvent fait en fait on est
avec l'équipe médicale du centre de jour
qui nous emmenait qui nous proposait sa
d'escaladé démarche
de ce que tu es là il ya la salle
d'escaladé avec betty mais petit
promontoire qu'ils enlèvent des fois
pour va on peut faire de tennis de foot
enfin il y avait vraiment du tout on
peut faire de la musculation parce
qu'ils étaient de musculation juste
derrière il ya des tables de ping pong
et ou quoi non moi je connais je vais
aller faire du sport ici aussi d'accord
quand j'étais enfant j'habitais là un
des cas les parents travaillent ici et
je venais faire du sport dans la salle
le dimanche vous prenez la clé
geovanni moi je vais faire du trampoline
voilà c'est là où je me baladais
pressions en tout temps tout le temps on
a eu du mal trois mois où les cinq jours
j'étais ici je me baladais je m'asseyais
sur le banc mais avec des amis et on
passe le temps comme ça la journée
[Musique]
on était loin du centre hospitalier mais
on pouvait se poser sur le crâne de se
faire prendre si on vous met une petite
bière ou un truc dans quoi
basse et mes amis qui les ramenait donc
on avait nous on n'a pas droit d'al qods
dans l'hôpital mais il des fois il y
avait des contrôles donc si on était
positif on pouvait avoir une fonction
virer où on
voit la cua tout comme ça c'est ça les
anciennes applications que vous habitiez
voilà moi j'habitais là derrière là
derrière le grillage et on venait voir
les poneys et aller à la salle de sport
et faire du vélo non par quoi ce que moi
aussi j'aimais bien
aussi j'avais bien dans le parc et il y
avait même des animaux aussi voyez
niveau là il ya entre la petite est
vraiment au fait qu'il n'y avait pas
chaud
[Musique]
c'est devenu beaucoup plus strictes un
moment je trouve la psychiatrie ou
disent que les gens doivent rester
enfermés faut mais je pense que c'est
dans les années
2000 2005 que ça commençait à devenir un
peu plus strictes ah oui tu t'en
souviens pas ouais ça a commencé quand
il ya eu les problèmes avec les pats les
attentats mais les problèmes on peut
appeler ça de
de violences dans l'est avec plusieurs
une montée de violence à cette époque là
et
son ca s'est refermée la sécurité dans
les hôpitaux psychiatriques en question
après le double homicide de pau le
ministre de la santé a promis des
mesures dans la région le centre
hospitalier d'erstein est un modèle du
genre
de 30 65
ce reportage confirma les souvenirs de
nos man il donne le ton de cette époque
où après avoir été un modèle d'ouverture
l'hôpital de mon enfant se retrouve à la
pointe des mesures sécuritaires
l'agressivité verbale de toute façon est
quasi quotidiennes mais des situations
litigieuses ou où les rapports de force
même physique oui c'est quelque chose de
peu présent dans notre travail était
très fréquentes une centaine de
téléphones a été distribués au personnel
soignant on les appelle tti poste
travailleurs isolés ils ont un bouton
d'alarmé et se déclenche seul en cas de
besoin l'équipe de sécurité qu'on voit
toujours à l'oeuvre dans l'hôpital
dachstein vient aussi de cette époque ce
mouvement sécuritaire connaît son apogée
fin 2008 suite à un autre crime commis
par un patient psychiatrique à grenoble
à l'époque mes parents ont déjà pris
leur retraite mais ils se souviennent de
ce discours de nicolas sarkozy qui
marque une vraie rupture après ce fait
divers les malades potentiellement
dangereux doivent être soumis à une
surveillance particulière
afin d'empêcher un éventuel passage à
l'acte
et vous savez fort bien mieux que moi
que des patients dont l'état s'est
stabilisé pendant un certain temps
peuvent soudainement
redevenir dangereux
alors
ça pose la question des moyens
il faut plus de sécurité protection dans
les hôpitaux psychiatriques
dix ans plus tard la psychiatrie tente
un nouveau virage le directeur dachstein
me parle de sa volonté d'ouvrir une
partie des services du bâtiment fermé ce
projet est porté par le successeur de ma
mère le médecin philippe meyer qui vient
le présenter à l'équipe infirmières donc
on se voit aujourd'hui dans le cadre de
notre réflexion sur
la réorganisation de notre unité dans le
cadre des nouvelles directives sur la
liberté d'aller et venir en aide à l'île
aux fleurs quand même content qu'on
passe à l'acte et qu'on lui organise
donc notre unité pour qu'il y ait dans
notre unité au moins une partie qui soit
entièrement ouverte n'a pas trop compris
il ya quelques années on va fermer les
dix on en n'est pas mon heure
là maintenant on continue à enfermer
dans les deux unités ouvertes qui sont
maintenant robot chez nous
après c'est tout à fait il ya des
patients qui effectivement ne nécessite
pas d'avoir une unité d'être en 8es
fermé
de là à l'aller c'est tout on verte
alors c'est vrai qu'actuellement il ya
des lits ouverts l'idée serait aussi de
sur ses douze lits qu'on souhaite ouvrir
que puisse y avoir des admissions
directes profond
bon ça va je feins c'est donc ça sera
une toute autre organisation pour nous
moi je dirais la difficulté c'est dans
le soin sait déjà que le patient soit
dans l'unité mais ça qu'il est verte
elle en avantages du patient mais pas
des soignants quoi parce que dans ses
parutions doit aller chercher eux ils
ont leur liberté en même temps la
sécurité se pose aussi un peu chez korn
ou y revienne si je prends il doit payer
10 pas quand ils reviennent en qui
peuvent rentrer dans le service avec les
produits sur eux enfin il ya aussi un
problème au niveau de la sécurité
venu nous on n'a pas attendu que l'on
maîtrise pense qu'on maîtrise pas la
question de la liberté d'aller et venir
pour moi il se pose surtout pour les
gens qui ne sont pas d'accord être là
pour les gens qui n'ont pas conscience
de leur trouve c'est pour ces patients
là qu'il faut se poser la question la
liberté d'aller et venir mais mais en
principe seront dans les unités ouvertes
les patientes qui sont hospitalisés
librement par exemple une personne avec
des idées des idées suicidaires qui
vient mais qui vient librement en
demandait si le médecin évalue que
effectivement les idées sont encore là
pour la protéger d'elle même on fait ce
qu'on appelle les élections des objets à
risque donc oui du coup si cette
personne elle traite mise en service
ouvert en aurait moi je suis pas sûr
qu'il porte fermée ça protège du suicide
je ne fassions pas dire comme ça et puis
dans le service on l'a à l'oeil on a des
caméras il ya les autres patients qui
surveille ce qui se passe la personne
n'est pas seul si le service est ouvert
la personne peut sortir aller dans le
parc et on parle quand même beaucoup de
surveillance
de précaution c'est l'agrégation la
surveillance la sécurité etc donc vous
êtes dans cette injonction là où nous
sommes aussi et puis et puis maintenant
on vous demande de lâcher quelque chose
de cette représentation la
chose dont on va revenir sur l'histoire
des fugues à me croyais à une fut la
première chose qu'on m'a demandé c'est
quoi est-ce qu'ils avaient droit de
sortir ce qu'elle pourra sortir
lorsqu'il est en santé accompagnée qu'il
a laissé sortir disent ok ben le patient
va avoir pas mal de liberté mais comment
on va concilier cette question de la
liberté avec les exigences de
surveillance
de contrôle et serment moi je leur ai
dit la liberté d'aller et venir c'est
pas que la liberté d'aller et venir
c'est aussi la liberté de faire des
conneries on ne pourra pas rendre
responsables les soignants de toutes les
conneries ou
de toutes les libertés que s'est octroyé
les patients dans ce cadre par contre
dans la façon de faire il va falloir un
accompagnement c'est sûr il a respect de
liberté d'un droit fondamental peut
passer à côté puis vous peuvent pas dire
pour des questions de confort personnel
cette liberté fondamentale va on la
supprime on l'a restera parce que moi ça
me convient pas moi c'est pas possible
parce que là comme je voulais qu'ils
c'est ma responsabilité
et si les contrôleurs des lieux de
privation de liberté vienne dans
l'établissement s'est pas l'expérience
et pas l'affirmer qu'ils auront trouvé
mais ses directeurs en disant monsieur
qu'avez-vous fait qu'à vous qu'avez vous
mis en place au sein de votre
établissement
andre hall ouvert la porte à 10 heures
ce matin qu'il a il n'est pas les
parents de services dans ces réunions
j'entends toutes les contradictions de
notre société gens d'un côté on demande
à la psychiatrie de s'ouvrir de l'autre
on refuse de prendre le moindre risque
nous allons prendre en compte
ces puits ont refait le point dans 4
à 10 heures
[Musique]
fidèle aux idéaux de l'époque de mes
parents je pensais prendre fait et cause
pour le principe de liberté porté par le
directeur
mais je me surprends à comprendre aussi
ces infirmiers qui ont peur d'être les
victimes de tous nos paradoxes
ça ne fait pas du tout plaisir de garder
des patients en fermer ou à l'hôpital
pendant pendant des mois ou des années
mais des semaines maintenant on a
beaucoup de patients hospitalisés
d'office
et donc nous on demande à ce qu'ils
aient des permissions des possibilités
de sortir d'avoir des activités à
l'extérieur et elles sont
systématiquement refusés en ce moment
par la préfecture
sur des raisons qu'on ne maîtrise pas
enfin qui sont souvent eux
qui sont pas feints qui pour nous sont
pas justifiées
parce qu'ils se protègent oui c'est les
politiques de ces cds balancier à un
moment donné bah oui il faut il ya la
liberté c'est toujours un peu les
injonctions paradoxales acquis qu'ils
existent et plus de liberté mais
attention dans certaines dents dans
certains moments où on dit pas laisser
sortir à veiller il ya des risques ces
principes de précaution et on joue
plutôt la contrainte et l'enfermement de
e-loue balancier là aujourd'hui
moi je dirais que le balancier plutôt
sur la liberté
en ce moment avec contrôleur des lieux
de privation de liberté les
recommandations de bonne pratique de la
haute autorité de santé le discours de
la ministre de la santé de la dame
madame busan que je partage totalement
moi je dirais qu'on est plutôt sur sur
cet aspect droits et libertés
ces regards
mais tu sais maman talf a dit que je
voulais je suis mais où on m'a dit tu
viens pas quitte à 10 à
[Musique]
alger vous si si il ya michel qui vient
manger chez moi
les jeunes voie
ouverte à ce vote
tu veux me chercher ouais vas manger
chez maman
elle t'a mis à vous
mais oui je t'ai vu oui
et tu as dit que tu étais contente de
voir lever de michel mais oui
à quelle heure on va après maintenant
quand tu es prête fin tu peux te
préparer puis on y va oui on va oui je
prends ma veste 2 1 mais je peux rien
donné ou mais tu dis rien à personne
on m'a mis des
la retraite en avant
mais je veux rien ne tient
le juge sur but et le procureur
il ya quelque chose qui a dopé
je veux le ramasser après
ouais
tout est pour nous un partenaire
de haut
vers l'hôpital oui
dans les mêmes eaux
du nil a
démoli jean on va où
mais le monsieur vous l'emmenez bah oui
oui t'inquiète on va l'emmener
[Musique]
ah bah oui certainement obama si vous
voulez jeter
certains vous le voulez oui moi je
prends avec
mais pour les couteaux tirés qui
contient
un joueur majeur suis à gauche tout à
coup les toits gauche pourquoi tu me
touches pas comme je dis qu'on gère non
non mais ça au ticket gaucher vol le
matin j'avais au leclerc ou dont tu as
de l'argent là sinon je le reçois rue
demain
et tous les soins
ils prennent leur petit appareil qui
s'est un petit peu ça
pour
preuve pour le maître total acier rues à
fouiller dans la série pour ouvrir la
porte husky qu'est-ce qui vient le soir
les fous issues de l'entourage de kraft
ses voeux qui vient le soir pour prendre
ton argent ils veulent mourir pour ça et
foule de la serrure pour rire
tu peux maintenant vous et comment tu
sais que c'est chéri est à l'armoire je
sais où le mettre et comment tu sais que
c'est eux
là je les connais c'est tous les soirs
les mêmes tous les soirs mais tu les
vois mais là je ne vois pas vraiment la
voiture tu as
il se touche devant ma porte c'est quoi
du coup là
qu'est ce que je vais chez le coach me
couche jet tours
et ça va mais oui je prends mes
médicaments et chez tour
aa qui se met à me libérer
[Musique]
bonjour ai dit qu'à
regarder je lis bellona regardez blue
cool
que que
irie qu ils recherchent des corridors et
les cas c'est amélie amélie regardez-moi
garde bonjour j'ai entendu beaucoup
parler vous par michel oui vous circule
pas passé avec la voiture la route non
heureusement mais michel m'a parlé vous
que tout car à la
whey
moyen étant enfant je savais pas que
c'était une ancienne patiente
s'est découvert enfin je n'ai découvert
plus tard étant enfant se dire quand
j'avais 7 ans 8 ans 9 ans
c'est quelque chose que je savais pas
puisque ben eric a toujours été là
puisqu'elle était là avant que je que je
que je sois né même il me semble
qu'elle commence à s'occuper de moi
voilà donc à erika et était là elle
était pas mal été et puis un fidelity
nous là qui ne s'occupait de nous quand
on rentrait de l'école en bus qui ne
vous est de goûter qui nous fait à
manger et c'est
bien beau jour j'ai dû la prendre part
je sais pas et de quelle façon mais ça a
rien changé finalement
pour moins connaître que nos parents le
milieu de la psychiatrie je pense que
c'est pas quelque chose que j'oserais
étant donné que je suis pas moi-même 6-4
et donc à même d'évaluer la fiabilité de
la personne que je vais choisir pour
garder notre fils
ouais
[Musique]
après vous moi je trouve qu eric à celle
de nos cuvées nous un web
ça s'est toujours très bien passé enfin
iliad accident quoi que ce soit
elle nous a également laissé
suffisamment de latitude de liberté peut
être qu'on nous encadrent en moins que
le ferait une nounou encadrées
réglementairement avec les standards
d'aujourd'hui
elle le souvenir précis de moments où tu
avais l'impression qu'elle était un peu
dépassé ah oui complètement enfin entend
jouer au terrain de jeu enfin nous ça
nous est arrivé
de faire des
bêtises monstrueuse
que quelqu'un de normal n'aurait pas pu
nous permettre de faire on descendait le
toboggan skateboard c'était des
des toboggans de l'époque qui n'était
pas du tout aux normes d'aujourd'hui
avec deux plateaux dont un qui était à
plus de six ou sept mètres de haut
descendez c'est en skateboard pendant
qu'elle nous garder elle était à côté
elle laissait fabricant but du tout
aller
[Musique]
après avoir travaillé près de 20 ans
chez nous erika n'a jamais retrouvé de
travail elle a vécu avec une invalidité
avant de toucher sa retraite c'est me
semble aujourd'hui comme livrée à
elle-même sans suivi
[Musique]
quelle place réservé en nous à ce qu
méricain et où pourrais-je maintenant
rencontrer ma nounou dans ce monde si
katherine qui attend évoluer
pas dans le service fermées pour les
patients en crise
pas dans les bâtiments des années 70
dont quelques uns fonctionne toujours en
service ouvert il accueille des
personnes stabiliser comme on dit mais
encore incapable de vivre à l'extérieur
contrairement à éric a
en outre avec 200 lits erstein contre 6
ans au départ les médecins réfléchissent
désormais à deux fois avant de spitz
elysées mais des innovations des années
70 continue de fonctionner comme les
hôpitaux de jour qui avec l'allocation
adulte handicapé permettent à des
patients d'être soigné de rentrer chez
eux j'y découvre des ateliers qui aide
les volontaires à affronter leurs mots
c'est là que la psychiatrie expérimente
maintenant là que je pourrais rencontrer
éric à aujourd'hui
[Musique]
que faire si j'ai des effets
indésirables avec mon médicament à
j'arrête de le prendre b je diminue la
12 c'est je le prends un jour sur deux
des gens par la longue 6 4
choisi notre
cas parce que je peux comprendre toutes
ces magnifiques sauf issus des personnes
trans ou fait d'apple ce sont des
passants qui ont cru que la guerre ah
oui ça peut être le fait d'avoir vécu
une guerre ça peut aussi avec le fait
d'avoir vécu dans une famille violentes
ou sainement tout type de traumatisme
julien parler avant du burn à des
difficultés au travail tout ça peut
potentiellement être un facteur de
stress qui peut déclencher une maladie
psychiatrique
si vous deviez changer quelque chose par
rapport à cette image stigmatisante
autour de la schizophrénie qu'est ce que
ce que vous ferez
comment vous aimeriez changer puis
changer d'environnement nouvelle vie
nouvelle identité
merci mais derrière
[Musique]
c'est quoi
je dirais tout simplement s'est fait
entendre des voix et puis
des fenêtres un peu absent
contre un peuple
dans la vie de tous les jours je sais
c'est quand même compliqué de suivi de
tous les matins et de sa ne pas savoir
si ça va bien se passer ou qui seraient
mal se passer vis-à-vis de mes symptômes
mais voilà
[Musique]
et du coup
vous avez l'impression que ce que vous
avez appris ici ça vous aide à mieux
oui oui ça va mieux comprendre les
symptômes et
mme accepté de ne pas être dans l'
isolement tout le temps cherché à sortir
à voir des gens sans importance à
ce qu'elle a dit est ce que la maladie
m'empêche de faire
dévaler chez moi je dis pas je fais les
choses de travers
[Musique]
on choisit pas toujours et on fait pas
toujours comment vous non plus on fait
comme on peut
cette raison que
j'aime bien c'est une porte de sortie
ouvrir cette porte voix se termine et
est plus malade que tu as envie de la
vie normale tout le monde
[Musique]
rkf et aussi certainement comme elle
peut elle liée avec ces voix mais semble
avoir trouvé une sorte d' équilibre sans
avoir à se battre contre la maladie et
contre les idées noires
ses idées noires qui pousse les patients
au suicide lors des phases de rechute
comme le craignent des infirmiers du
pavillon fermé
malgré leurs réticences le projet
d'ouverture est maintenant sur les rails
peu après les réunions les fameux
contrôleur des libertés ont effectué une
visite dans l'hôpital d'erstein
ils ont salué le projet mais je découvre
à mon retour qu'ils ont posés eux aussi
le problème de l' architecture
on avait parlé de l' architecture saas a
été soulevée quand on arrive dans une
unité où on a
comment dire comme comme un bocal avec
l'ensemble des infirmiers à l'intérieur
derrière des écrans où il ya de la
vidéosurveillance et que les patients
sont dans les couloirs ça ça a été ça a
été soulevée par les contrôleurs des
lieux de privation de liberté en disant
qu'en effet les professionnels mais je
pense que c'est le cas dans la majorité
des cas les professionnels doivent
accompagner les patients être auprès des
patients est pas isolé derrière derrière
une vitre ou derrière un bocal à
regarder les écrans de télé des écrans
de surveillance
ça c'est ça pour le coup c'est un choix
architectural qui a été fait à une
époque
le bâtiment date de 2014 va pas le raser
pour en construire un autre ça veut dire
que des conceptions de sécurité qui ont
un budget validé par les pouvoirs
publics en 2014 elles sont déjà périmé
aujourd'hui pour les mêmes institutions
lorsqu'elle était périmé est-ce qu'elles
sont périmés dès à présent ou est-ce
qu'en 2014 elle était déjà périmé ça a
été une comment dire un pari
architectural une option de soins qui a
été prise à l'époque voilà
[Musique]
pourquoi avoir délaissé les pavillons
ouvert de l'hôpital village où les beau
bâtiment centenaire de celui de hoerdt
les lieux où j'ai vécu tomberont bientôt
en ruine alors qu'il conviendrait
finalement beaucoup mieux aux besoins
d'aujourd'hui que le grand bâtiment
fermé anonyme
[Musique]
mais peut-être est-il plus simple de
mettre de l'argent pour bâtir de
nouveaux lieux que de miser sur l'humain
et l'humain justement où en est-il au
gré des tâtonnements visible dans le
décor de mes photos
l'asile où le mental ce qu'on juge
incapable de vivre en société les
pavillons ouvert d'une époque qui se
veut en pointe de l'humanisme puis les
grilles et les portes que l'on referme à
clé pour limiter les risques en
cloisonnant le monde à chaque époque sa
vision du fou de la normale
qu'ils oublient que dumas réserve des
surprises
or c'est bien d'une surprise que j'ai en
retournant dans l'hôpital d'erstein
poursuivre les pilotes du projet
d'ouverture bonjour tout le monde donc
on se revoit au bout d'un mois
d'ouverture une partie donc cinq
semaines qu'on aille vers une partie du
pavillon donc on a 12 digue le 3 juin
voilà ça fait cinq semaines que ça
fonctionne
[Musique]
répondre aux discussions difficiles ce
qui n'est pas défini ce qui est mieux ce
qui est moins bien à ce qui est
compliqué pour ma part en tout cas je
craignais plutôt le côté ouvert rennes
parce qu'on avait plus est en crise les
patients de leur présence est donc là ça
se passe très bien quelques-uns qui
demandait beaucoup qu'on les accompagne
juste pour aller qu'on ait un café
maintenant ils peuvent aller tout seul
c'est super drôle de soignants fait
j'ai remarqué dans des temps depuis que
s'est ouvert lorsque ce un hasard ou ou
pas comme moi je suis beaucoup plus
sollicité l'appui shrine que les
entretiens affirmé où les passions
normalement via nous solliciter quand il
sort quand il rentrait viennent ils
viennent chez nous il ya nous voir
ouais on est dans l'action et
non franchement ça se après c'est aussi
peut-être les patients qui ont
consommé dans ce service qui sont qu'ils
sont pareils en avril et qui sont
parfaitement adaptés à ce vent de l'est
de pas bien et on a aussi revu de toutes
façons de voeux de travailler où on est
quand même dans le tout sécuritaire et
tout était régi par un règlement est
maintenant en fin de compte on
s'aperçoit qu'on ne reste toute la
liberté et on fait plutôt on fait des
petites restrictions sur sur certaines
choses moissac sénat sont positives
et plus pris à partie parce que juste
pour les questions de bien-être ils ont
pas réussi à sortir tout de suite là en
fait ils ont leur liberté du cui sont
moins dans la plainte aussi à nous à
nous faire des reproches choses comme ça
on retrouve plus sa de scholes et qu'on
avait découvert des des patients qu'on
avait depuis longtemps côté fermé qui
s'était un peu éteint qui s'était kiss
et kill mon père mais qui demande des
parents qui nous demandaient pas grand
chose à part de là où les rapports qui
existent entière il vomit du côté ouvert
ils ont retrouvé une certaine liberté
qu'il aurait été bénéfique et qui a été
enfin qui a été excusé pour leur suite
d'hospitalisation qui c'est qui s'est
arrêtée très libère
peut-être qu'il serait pas sorti au
civic si nous allons regarder plus
longtemps côté côté fermé mais c'est
quand même
comme vous dites une catégorie de
patients qu'on aurait quand même mis
dans une unité fermée
et ça ça pose qui finalement maintenant
ça pose question
[Musique]
on
ça n'a l'air de rien comme ça ouvrir
ouvrir douze lits finalement c'est pas
grand chose c'est que ça peut se réduire
à une question technique une question
juridique ça revient bien au delà
ça nous renvoie aussi si je peux me
l'autorisé un
à une dialectique de foucault sur la sur
la société sécuritaire et les sociétés
sécurisante
ces deux notions finalement
qui sont presque posés par certains
aspects et là nous on en fait on en fait
l'expérience je veux dire
on a l'impression d'être plus sécurisant
en ayant mis un cadre finalement moins
sécuritaire
[Musique]